We do have hatriot mail for you this week. Hatriot
mail really escalating, I guess I would say.
Quick reminder about what hatriot mail is
to the over two hundred thousand Americans
who died from Koven 19. You'll let
it dominate your life, didn't you?
Hey, Terry, it may be written by
patriots who hate David Pakman
because of America and because freedom.
Lots of people very, very angry
with me for some reason and in advance of the
election. Take a listen to this one as it needs
very little introduction. But it is. This is
a viewer is weighing in on the Supreme Court
nomination. That's how I would introduce it if it
was not the rantings of a lunatic. Take a listen.
Soy boy, cuk boy, PAC man, fill the seats,
winning one, winning Schrum forever. I'd put
money up that PAC man is either a cook or
gay. Don't tell. This guy likes to gossip.
That's what I think of when I see soft, pale
intellectuals who aren't actually about America
or freedom and a Jew to boot. Full package.
So you've got a combination there of gender
stereotypes about alpha and beta males,
anti-Semitism, which is just a fixture of
hatriot male and it has been for years, really
just like a mishmash of nonsense. Now, here's
this is a serious question. I actually
want to hear from people on this,
as opposed to many of the things I say. I don't
really want to hear from you. This one, I really
do. What kind of a job do you think folks who
write e-mails like this have? Like, could this be
an accountant that emailed me about being a suck
a soy boychuk boy? Is it possible that this is a
pediatric oncologist that wrote me this? I'm
not. I don't want to stereotype. Who would
write such an email? But what do you imagine
would be the day to day job of somebody like
that if they even have a job? I don't know the
answer to that. What do you imagine? Let me know
and remember that you can use the coupon code
hatriot 40 to get 40 percent off the membership
of your choice on my Web site. Join Pacman dot
com. Here's the spelling and there's confusion
about the spelling. It's HKT like a hat. HKT r
i o t hat. Riot like the two words. HHC Brierty
four zero 40 percent off the membership
of your choice at join Pacman dot com